Microsoft and Google you know the big
thing back in the day was you know these
brain teaser interviews and puzzles and
this and that and that has sort of
evolved what were your sort of learnings
about the interviewing given that you
were there from the very almost the very
beginning your learnings about the
interview process and how that filtered
candidates I think that does a pretty
good job
you thought the interview process worked
well yeah I think you want to understand
the person their motivation I think you
want to understand their academic
records because most of these are folks
coming off college campuses and I think
you want to understand people's ability
to problem-solve I always gave this
problem the kids I'm thinking of a
number between one and 100
you can guess after each guest I'll tell
you whether high or low you get it the
first guess I'll give you five bucks
four bucks three two one zero
you pay me a buck you pay me two you pay
me three and the question is do you want
to play or not
what's your answer of course what's my
answer okay my answer I'm not trying to
get you to do it on camera it's actually
quite a hard part okay fifty okay
higher low your low uh seventy-five your
high 60
uh you are low sorry your high 55 you
are low 57
you are high our low rather 58 you are
low 59 yeah seven guesses Sam I got you
owe me a buck so what do you like what
did you learn about me just then I
learned that you need to step back
not in that with the pressure the
cameras and really ask whether you
should expect to win or lose money on
this thing because I think we expect
probabilistically probably there's two
things that are true probabilistically
will you make or lose money you will
lose money why there are far more
numbers on which you lose the numbers on
which you win even with your strategy
and number two I can pick numbers
specifically that are hard for you to
get okay so I should say I don't want to
play the game at all how many people
actually said that
the number who and they're literally
there's one guy interviewed at Purdue
and he said well here's the answer and
he actually wrote down this quickly I
gave him the problem he said well here's
the answer wrote it down and said this
is the expected value of the game I'm
sorry I'm just not fit for a job at
Microsoft well not as a program right
I'm not backing in other professions
we're talking literally in the tech okay
it turns out it's a binary search
problem it's classic in computer science
it's masquerading as this guessing game
it was a pretty good problem teased out
the way people